FEES AMOUNT OF HIS WORD, HE WILL
LET'S GET REACTION OUT FROM
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL MIKE
McKAY ZANE.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
YOU JUST HEARD FROM THE
CONGRESSMAN, THIS IS WILD.
THE JUSTICE THAT YOU HAVE
RECEIVED ALL THE DOCUMENTS THAT
YOU ARE ESSENTIALLY ENTITLED TO.
WHERE ARE WE TENANT, JUDGE?
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN THE SUBPOENA
WE WOULD HAVE TO DO MORE
DISCUSSING BETWEEN AND AMONGST
>> Laura: IT LOOKS LIKE THE
DOCUMENTS NUNEZ REQUESTED WERE
ABOUT INFORMANTS PLACED INSIDE
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, OR WHO
APPROACH THE DRUM CAMPAIGN.
INVESTIGATION REALLY BEGAN.
INDICATIONS ARE THAT IT BEGAN
WELL INVOLVED, CHRISTOPHER
STEELE                    CHRISO
STEELE                    CHRISH
ABOUT.
AND WHO WAS THE IMPETUS JUDGE
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO KNOW
INTERESTED IN EXAMPLE, KNOWING
HOW THIS INFORMANT, WHO STARTED
REALLY PLAY WITH EACH OTHER'S
TOYS AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
THAT HAPPENED, WHO BROUGHT IT
THINK THAT WE OUGHT TO KNOW THAT
AS WELL.
FAILURE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
TO REVEAL WHO THESE STAFF
ATTORNEYS ARE.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE ESTHER
KLEINSMITH WAS WRITING
UNBELIEVABLE TEXT MESSAGES THAT
HE WAS SO DEPRESSED AFTER THE
ELECTION, HE WAS STRESSED AND
DEPRESSED.
AND AT THE HEART OF THIS
INVESTIGATION ALONG WITH STRZOK
AT LEAST TO ME, IS NOT JUST THE
STATEMENTS ABOUT THE RESISTANCE
BUT RATHER, A SET OF MESSAGES
THAT PASS BETWEEN STRZOK AND HIS
FRIEND THE NIGHT THAT
DONALD TRUMP OUT THE NOMINATION,
WHERE SHE WROTE TO HIM THAT IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE TRUNK OUT OF
NOMINATION.
AND HE HE SAID THIS INCREASES
THE PRESSURE TO TERMINATE AND
WHY E, WHICH WAS THE CODE NAME,
MADE YOUR EXAM, FOR THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S NOT JUST AN EXPRESSION OF
OPINION, THAT'S A STATEMENT OF
IN THE IG REPORT, I DON'T RECALL
SEEING THAT.
AND I THINK THAT SOMETHING THEY
HAVE TO QUESTION STRZOK ABOUT
WHEN HE TESTIFIES.
>> Laura: AND JUDGE, HE WAS
JUST WALKED OUT OF THE DOJ LAST
WEEK.
APPARENTLY JUST LOST HIS
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
I NEVER WORKED AT DOJ.
I'VE WORKED AT THE WHITE HOUSE
AND TRANSPORTATION EDUCATION,
SUPREME COURT.
I'VE NEVER WORKED AT DOJ BUT IF
THAT'S THE WAY BUSINESS IS DONE
AT THE DOJ, WE ARE IN BIG
TROUBLE IN THIS COUNTRY.
BIG TROUBLE.
>> DOESN'T INSPIRE CONFIDENCE,
NOR DOES SOMETHING THAT WAS
REPORTED IN THE IG REPORT,
NAMELY THAT THEY WERE FBI AGENTS
IN ADDITION TO THE PRESS GETTING
THREE MEALS AND FREE TICKETS AND
OTHER PERKS, AND THAT THERE WERE
SO MANY OF THEM.
THAT WAS AN ABSOLUTE JAW
DROPPER.
THE NOTION THAT FBI AGENTS WERE
GETTING COMPENSATION COME
ESSENTIALLY COME FROM REPORTERS